[Music]
lou is in phoenix hi lou how are you
i'm good how are you better than i
deserve how can we help
okay well i'm calling because i just i'm
at a kind of a crossroads and i want to
be really strategic because i have like
i'm older i'm 56 and i i don't have a
lot of time left for you know my working
career and i'm divorced and
unfortunately i don't have a huge 401k
i'm renting and i just got noticed my
rent's going up 300
um and so i've been hearing i mean i
know what you're going to say but um
you know i have like 7
900 left in debt it should be paid off
by march 2023
what do you mean um
sixty thousand
but um
i just don't know what to do i have
people my friends and everything
i'm sorry why does it take twelve months
to pay off seven thousand dollars when
you make sixty
well
um well i have to take i have my um i
take three percent from my 401k and then
i'm sorry what
i put three percent away from my 401k
you know of my income and then also i
have my hsa that i've been putting like
125 per paper per pay period it's every
two weeks
um
stop both
stop both of those
stop both of those okay here's what's
happening with you okay
and it happens with most people
you're trying to do a little bit of
everything that's smart and nothing's
moving
okay you're trying a hundred dollar into
one thing
300 into another thing and you're nickel
and diming and you've got no focus at
all to the math it's all spread out and
when you when light dispersed simply
lights the room
light focused is a laser you can do
surgery with
okay and you're dispersing all of your
financial energies across a whole bunch
of things and not moving the needle on
any of them
okay
does that make any sense
oh yeah
that's why that's why we teach the baby
steps do you have any money in savings
that's not retirement
well i have that one thousand dollar i
actually have 1200 in for my emergency
fund because i'm trying to you know
follow the steps
um but my like i said my rent's going up
300. and it's just um okay yeah so
here's what i would tell you to do what
do you do for a living
i work in um i do loans uh legal
documents for commercial banking okay
all right
cool
okay uh i i would tell you two or three
things if if you were my little sister
and you'd be about the age of my little
sister okay
um i i would tell you let's let's do the
baby steps exactly like you were a
pharisee about them okay and that means
one thousand dollars not twelve hundred
dollars it means you stop putting money
in hsa you stop putting money in
retirement and you get on a really tight
beans and rice rice and beans budget and
we knock out this debt in six months or
four months not in 12.
okay and then we get the emergency fund
up to three to six months of expenses
and then we start saving aggressively to
buy a house and i think if you do all of
that plus one more thing i'm going to
tell you um that you're probably buying
a house
by christmas of 23
18 18 months
okay but the other but i mean i'm gonna
put you on beans and rice girl you're
spending money right now you don't have
a lot of money
i'm not saying you're crazy and out of
control or something but you're gonna
find money when you make this pretend
like you had a health problem and if you
didn't save up fifteen thousand dollars
to pay for the medical bill you were
gonna die
okay
that kind of thing i mean like that kind
of intensity
that like i ain't doing nothing
okay you don't need to see the inside of
a restaurant unless you're working there
and don't you talk to me about a
vacation we're trying to get a house
exactly you know i totally hear you
yeah you sell so much stuff the kids
think they're next put the cat on ebay
and the dog on craigslist
i'm kidding not really but maybe not
about the cat but and then the other
thing i'm going to tell you is with ken
coleman's going to help you with this
other thing i'm going to tell you is i
want you to start thinking about what
you can do to make more money not only
in the short term
take an extra job and work your butt off
but also in the long term what what
career moves can ken coleman help you
make to go make 80 000 or 90 000 and
change your whole life you like you said
you got a decade or so left to work
let's go make some money and put it away
so we can retire with dignity ken yeah i
want you to do a little exercise and i
want you to after you do this exercise i
want you to run it by three or four
people that you really know well and
that you respect their opinion here's
the exercise i want you to write down
your working life i want you to write
down
all of the experience that you have that
is really relevant to just about any
industry what i mean by that is you're
very detail-oriented process oriented in
the type of work you do now true or
false
yeah true very true okay good so i want
you to think of all of that valuable
experience and just get it out of your
head and write it down could be a list
of five things could be 15 could be 50.
and then i want you to focus on what you
do really really well what are your
talents these could be people skills
could be some technical skills as well
once you get that out on paper so
experience on one column and talent on
the other and that's going to show you
what you have the offer uh what you have
to offer to this marketplace and we are
in a job economy right now certainly
where you are
where you have a lot to offer and i want
you to be able to see yourself a little
bit differently run that list by some
people go hey based on this list of
experience that i bring to the table
and talent i bring to the table what
ideas do you have let other people who
aren't kind of in their own in your
world they're in their world they see it
objectively let them give you some ideas
this is a brainstorming exercise is what
i've just given you okay now you're
gonna see opportunities that you haven't
seen before okay
and then i want you to uh we're going to
give you when we put you on hold we're
going to give you my get clear career
assessment take you about 20 minutes and
i want you to take that after you do
that first homework assignment and
you're going to begin to see yourself
and see some real purpose and some
opportunities you've never seen before
go put yourself out there side hustle
for sure
but
can you transition can you pivot find
something you think you could get and go
interview that makes 80. right now and
let's get a big bump
and let's just see what we can make can
we make 80 or 90 000 what would it take
to get to six figures you got a decade
to where you can really stack up some
money and get out of this debt-free
journey pretty quickly just on where you
are but let's juice it with some more
income yeah you can ask yourself what
henry cloud talks about your desired
future okay this is my desired future
and then you ask yourself okay what has
to be true yes for me to be there that's
not true today that may mean i need to
take a class that may mean i need to put
myself out there and go interview it may
mean um maybe you can walk right in
there and get it but you just hadn't
bothered
because what happens is sometimes um
we get uh out of a fear of rejection
or um
you know because if somebody doesn't
hire you that's very personal that's
right
out of a fear of rejection we can kind
of get stuck yeah and go well i'm just
gonna i'm just gonna ride this thing out
i'm just gonna ride this horse on out
he'll take me home but he's not very
fast but he'll get me home tell you
something else that happens and it may
be happening in lou's case but what we
focus on is what we see
so neuroscience did all this study in uh
decades ago and found that we have this
thing in our brain called the reticular
activating system very fancy work here's
what it means
for all of you that ever bought a car
you remember seeing that car
everywhere for like four or five days
after you bought it it's remarkable you
know it's like oh there's our car
there's our car and did the god of cars
just drop that car into your world no
what happens is they've proven that what
we focus on is what we see everywhere so
if you have victim type thinking you
start feeling attacked everywhere you go
and she does she doesn't sound like a
victim no no no but the idea is what we
focus on is what we see so if you're
looking to focus on opportunity right
but if you have grades yeah if you go i
only got a decade left there's not a lot
of opportunity out there for me then we
see that everywhere so if we switch it
wait a second i've got a decade a decade
and a half a day you know of
of real worth and work that i can do
then we begin to see opportunities that
were sitting in front of us the entire
time that's the idea what we focus on
our brain goes out and takes pictures of
it and gives us evidence of it so when
we change what we focus on and what we
think we begin to see things we've never
seen before and that's what this
exercise that i gave her that will help
her to begin to see herself differently
than maybe she's ever seen herself
before what's the old yeah it's old earl
nightingale from the 60s classic you
know what you can conceive and believe
conceive it you can see it in your mind
conceive it yeah and believe it can be
true you can achieve
great words hopefully you're not
delusional and so hopefully what you're
conceiving is actual yeah and you know
what you can conceive and believe
you can achieve and we're not talking
about the american idol dropouts here
okay you actually know how to sing
and you can conceive and believe it